We're back at the Asian grocery store doing a little restock.
It's one of our favourite places
but we don't go a lot cause it's so far away.
But today was the day!
I always start in the produce section
and always have to grab a papaya and stock up on some mushrooms.
There's just something about all the produce.
Today I decided to get some Thai chillies,
Guylon, and some pre peeled garlic.
I also needed some green onions,
some bean sprouts, and some Napa cabbage.
I usually get the stuff that I would need
for some recipes I'm trying to make,
so today I also decided to grab some tofu.
Lucky's always in charge of the meat
so he grabbed whatever he thought we needed.
Skip the sodas today,
just got some juice and then made it over to the ramen section.
I don't usually eat ramen so lucky picked his favorites.
And then I got some mi gorengue for my sister in law that was coming
because I remember that she really liked these.
We also got a small bag of rice
and then made it over to grab some kimchi.
I could have kimchi with every single meal.
Especially with some sweet potato.
Lucky grabbed some of his favorite pot stickers
and we also got some gyoza for condiments.
We kept it pretty simple today
and I saw this pina colada that I knew lucky would like
so I grabbed that for him and then we Checked out
the total wasn't bad today at all.
We made sure to only get the essentials.
And then we saw this little game area
and decided to win the kids a prize for heading home.